you wrote a much talked about um opinion
about the slap and what it meant
and can you expand upon that about what
you thought about that moment and how it
affected people i just felt that will's
wife
really should have been given some
consideration as to you know how she
felt about it
and what she wanted to do about it i
mean they just ignored her
altogether and i i didn't
i didn't think that made much sense you
know she's the one that would have been
offended if
if it was offense it wasn't you know
like
somebody like riding her you know
it was
you never know you know
what people are thinking
so you know that's
how i see it introducing the souring
point guard from the midwest
johnson
there is a unique partnership between
the two of you and initially did you
know that it would
that did you think it would work
well you know uh after the first
i'd say
five or ten games that we played i knew
better things were happening and then
they kept getting better and you know we
won the world championship that year
and went on to win four more so uh
it wouldn't have happened without urban
it wouldn't have happened without a lot
of the guys on the team you know it was
a great
combination of guys that
work together hard and we love each
other and
we sacrifice for each other because of
the hiv virus that i have attained uh
i will have to retire from the lakers
you know you talk about the sacrifices
and how you got hard you guys work but
we look at magic right now irvin and we
think back to that day that he made the
announcement and we thought oh my gosh
we're going to lose this man to see him
here today how important is that well i
think it's great that you know urban has
been able to
survive and be a spokesperson for
uh aids consciousness and uh
he's still out here doing good things in
the community
and now we're going to find out what a
story is all about so you know i'm
really anxious to do that that should be
fun and
i'll learn a few more things
[Music]